let me just summon myself
welcome back to new rock stars it's a
new year it's a new dawn it's a new day
my headphone fell out of my ear it's a
new mcu
we've got lots of exciting new projects
coming in from marvel this year maybe
something uh about a huskier gentleman
who can move so fast but knocks things
over in the grocery store i don't know
just pitch in here that means it's time
to make some bold predictions that will
make us look ridiculous months later and
i'm sure
maybe even days later and god i know
you'll let us know in the comments you
guys are so good at keeping us in check
and very bad at complimenting i
guarantee myself that daredevil is going
gonna appear in the new cw nancy drew
adaptation that's my you can put a tommy
guarantee on it a little tommy stamp
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is thomas
michael bechtold and i'm a catholic man
a man of great faith today going rogue
with me is the prognosticator of the
powerful the love of my life my queen my
muse
the subject of all of my erotic fan
fiction jessica clemens hi jessica
[Laughter]
uh just fan fiction it's not erotic it's
a coloring book basically it's just us
holding hands on a rainbow
also the host of the mass effect
adventure podcast the subject of all of
my erotic fan fiction and the superstar
of superheroes it's matt joseph
hello man how are you i'm doing great
tommy you're infectious man you're like
a reverse goku spirit bomb like you're
giving me energy you know i'm like wow
i'm awake all right let's do it
let's get it going you know it's uh it's
a thursday let's let's treat these
thursdays like fridays guys it's just
friday junior and finally the omnipotent
oracle of overpowered beings and the
subject of all of my erotic fiction it's
erica wusu eric i've missed you so much
welcome back i miss you too tommy i love
that you presented by the ghost of rick
flair for this episode
i did drink a coke zero
beforehand uh and i did have two diet
cokes at lunch
so
perhaps the this is this the caffeine
talking oh i'm just excited because we
have such a great panel today and eric
vos ain't here to tell us no he's not in
the office we can do whatever we want i
can play with all the action figures
these earbuds i got from 7-eleven can
keep falling out of my ears
anyway they're not they're not an
official sponsor because these earbuds
suck let's talk spider-man guys
spider-man no way home was full of
cameos and special appearances but our
first big one came from the man without
fear but when will we see him next that
leads us to today's first topic
daredevil's next appearance after
appearing early in a spider-man norway
home very early so early i had just
finished my last pretzel bite shout out
to mt
uh as the legal counsel to peter parker
and happy hogan charlie cox matt murdock
now joins the mcu as an already agile
daredevil vigilante hiding his powers
with new reports the writers that worked
on the netflix daredevil and punisher
series are joining the staff of the echo
spin-off series
where can we expect to see daredevil
next is it going to be an echo moon
knight she-hulk as my i may have
mentioned nancy drew already what do you
guys think you say nancy drew
that's right
yeah the cw remake
my bad my bad my bad for being ignorant
uh how dare
you yeah you know uh i do think i think
that uh you know off the bat i do think
that daredevil's gonna appear
in uh she-hulk i think that'll be the
first appearance of daredevil i don't
know if he's gonna have a significant
role in she-hulk uh but i definitely
think we're gonna be seeing more in in
like the
disney plus tv series i think that's
gonna be the intro for him you know
we're dealing with lawyers clearly you
know do we know jennifer it deals with
uh repping superheroes as well uh we saw
that matt uh also in spiderman no way
home this is great that we could talk
about this by the way and no way home he
shows up uh and he's repping peter
parker you know um so
they're gonna collide at some point
maybe maybe they're even like working
together that'd be pretty cool but uh i
definitely think their past will cross
originally there for sure i i love that
now you they are both attorneys as you
said do you think uh they'll be they'll
be taking on a very specific
high-profile client or do you want to
speculate or prognosticate on uh are
that will they be co-counsel or will
they be against each other oh that's
interesting uh
um
you know i kind of think that
they might be against each other at
first i i don't know why but i have a
feeling that she-hulk is going to be the
intro to inhumans again like the
reintroduction of humans
uh and maybe there's like people are
going crazy because of these inhumans
and like ah you know it's like wow they
can't be running the streets so maybe
like you know she's defending like
someone within human powers or something
and uh and matt murdock like helps her
out with that uh to be specific i can't
think of anything off the top and here
yeah
yeah well i don't mean to cut you off
i'm just saying that when tommy hosts
specifics are at a minimum okay
yeah inhumans is like
that's out that's like i never got
touched in humans i think x-men inhumans
i never really got like into so yeah
that's okay that's all right you know
what in humans i only know from that uh
hulu show that ran like eight episodes
and had the guy who played um
uh roose bolton's son
right that guy he was in it we all
remember that is that the specifics
you're looking for folks moving along
who's got another theory
i have one tommy
all right um i have one mr beck told uh
i also agree oh my god
that's in my writings
this
is
it's one called substitute teacher
i should i'll send you the i'll send it
send me the rough draft i'll edit it
that's the coloring book though oh
what okay
matt i agree with the matt i agree with
matt especially for next appearances
because i do think she-hulk is going to
come before my theory of
seeing charlie cox in um an echo so um
since we already saw them in spider-man
i think the next place since we have
we're getting into like some law stuff i
think echo is going to have the next one
that's going to be like very high in law
other than she-hulk where it's going to
be like hey
you did a lot of illegal stuff and also
we had um
her merged echo merged with vincent
d'onofrio so i think all of that like
gang violence stuff is gonna cross paths
with charlie cox and it's gonna be like
i'm on your side and here is why but we
need to find a way to get you off of all
these charges so i think that would be a
next time we would see them but i do
think ultimately like she-hulk would be
just a great appearance because of the
two battling it out uh and i do think
that one comes before echo does but if
echo did come first i then i think it's
echo but i think it's that guy
yeah so it's over it's so it's it's a
situation of release dates here
i think so yeah
i i have to say i i i prefer when the
superheroes put their powers away and
take it to the courts and settle it in
the courts like you know dignified human
beings let's get litigious instead of
super powered that's what i as what i
always say
uh eric what do you got for us well i'm
gonna come with the rogest of the rogue
theories today okay all right also
because matt and jessica said both of my
two first options
welcome welcome to my world eric every
time i do this
[Laughter]
charlie cox's daredevil is going to pop
up in echo or she-hulk i think he's
going to pop up first and foremost in
moonlight i think he's going to follow
over moon knight because they're both
kind of street level uh marvel
characters they're not big magic or
interstellar type of characters i think
they're gonna uh meet up there or
charlie cox's daredevil is gonna show up
there
also they're two superheroes of the
night
uh i think that'll play a good part of
it there definitely
his stuff at night he don't need to see
in the night in the day anyway and also
uh moon knight his character has a
dissociative disorder so he has
different people so i think something
might happen where he gets in trouble
with the law as his you know regular
secret identity self and charlie cox's
daredevil i don't know why i keep
introducing this charlie classes
yeah
daredevil
there is only one yeah i need to stop
saying that too the formality we gotta
keep that formality that's right with a
multi-dimensional uh uh cameo by
daredevil played by ben affleck of
course
charlie cox's daredevil will pop up and
have to defend moon knight in court
because you know his secret identity
will be wilding out he'll have to defend
with all the dissociative uh disorder
characters and then that's how we'll see
daredevil first and foremost next in the
mcu
i i could see that i was also going to
say that in moonlight and
please don't come for me i read moon
knight so long ago and i was just like
he's kind of a brat um but
so that's why i didn't go further with
it that much but
because there's so much uh in the
original ones that i read they were
stealing there's just so much artifact
stealing and a lot of stuff doing with
museums and a lot of rich people
business it was all rich people going at
it together he's basically a bruce wayne
type so i think him mixing with charlie
cox being invited to like a party
because you know there's gonna be a
scene where there's gonna be a giant
like
uh charity banquet at a museum just like
there was in hawkeye just like there
isn't all of them if there's gonna be an
auction and charlie cox is gonna be
sitting there like what's gonna happen
what's gonna happen i can't wait to see
a great point and i do i i do think that
like at the end to add on to this theory
which is such a fun theory i think that
the the you know the head of it all will
be kingpin uh i think he's gonna go for
mayor like he's currently he's mayor in
the comic books a very corrupt mayor uh
we're dealing with him
the the the fallout of that right now in
the comics but i think that we're gonna
get mayor fisk he's gonna use the blind
stuff uh he's get to his advantage he's
going to you know get these artifacts
and manipulate people to do that so
maybe it's like this is just like a
giant game of chess for maybe a future
daredevil series that's building up just
like some ultimate climax between uh
charlie clarkson's daredevil and uh uh
kingpin
i love these things you gotta keep it
grounded especially with like
superheroes well what tommy said earlier
about like i'm tired of all the super
powers willy-nilly
like you need to keep that [ __ ] grounded
sometimes movies are too loud
rich people get their business done in
three places the golf course the
courtroom
and and crooked auctions in museums okay
so that's yes i think everybody's theory
is good i gotta roll my rolling chair
back for one second so we can award some
points hang on
also
i guess
oh yeah oh yeah yeah this week i'm not
in charge of doling out the points for
rogue theory this week wwe hall of famer
sean michaels will be giving out sweet
chin musics for all the theories that he
likes so let's get him in position
he's tuning up the band as they say as
uh good old jr used to say and uh
matt
for your uh for your introduction of uh
the inhumans back into the mcu and maybe
done with that fighty golden touch
i'm gonna give you two sweet chin musics
boom boom
all right and jessica for you're you
know kind of just
taking matt's theory and making it a
little bit your own and you know adding
and then adding a couple of new
addendums to it but you know basically
just massaging uh
your your your re you rebooted matt's
theory much like the inhumans
i'm gonna give you one sweet chin music
shawn michaels and eric
for just you know pivoting on the fly
and and bringing in a a a rogue theory
out of left field i'm gonna give you
two sweet team musics but one is to a
stick a finger figure marty janetti
through brutus the barber beefcake's
barbershop window so the most famous
sweet chin music of all time so let's
keep track of those guys those are very
official points that will count towards
a major prize at the end of this episode
no
that's right so everyone can please keep
track up next we're going to discuss
which new series will have the biggest
impact on the uh next year but first
time for a little plugs okay here is
some crazy news you can see me
jessica clemons eric boss
phillip k molina in person
and live
in the city of dreams the city of stars
i call it la east la center la midwest
chicago baby chicago
on february 11th so close to valentine's
day but no kissing because of that kron
kron new rock stars is doing a cool live
show with our friends at rooster teeth
podcast and the face jam podcast at the
i'm gonna pronounce this wrong talia
hall thalia hall it's one of the two
remember the singer talia as part of the
very normal podcast tour that's right
we're going on tour baby will i play
guitar no because i don't play an
instrument check the link in the video's
description or new rockstar social media
accounts for ticket info that's right
you can see me jessica eric and phillip
live in person show up in one of the new
rock stars one division or far from home
shirts and i will point at you from at
least six feet away and say cool shirt
my dad's somewhere in this city will you
help me find him all right guys
i'd love to meet him love to meet him
this is my year
folks i want to talk to you about a
little company that's helped me for sure
what would you do if you didn't have a
high interest loan or credit card debt
would you move to a new city buy a new
car finish that yondu cosplay you've
been dreaming of well through upstart
you can pay off your existing debt
quickly with a personal loan so you can
tackle your next big financial goal for
me
it's building a life-size thanos that i
can hug and hold in bed okay and he's
gonna have the ass he's gonna have the
thano cheeks because that's what i'm
gonna hold on to at night all right
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal experiences over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date that's nice it's nice when
things pay off especially when it's debt
upstart knows you're more than just your
credit score so rather than just looking
at that upstart ma upstart's model
considers factors like your income
employment and other info provided in
your loan application to find you a
smarter rate sick of those dumb rates
that can barely pass their algebra class
get you a smart rate check out your rate
without impacting your credit score in
just five minutes
for loans between 1 000 to 50 000
that's like winning a game show for
crying out loud receive funds as fast as
one business day after accepting your
loan find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
rogue
that's upstart.com rogue don't forget to
use our url to let them know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
rogue one of my favorite things to do
is buy illegal worms on the black market
and send them to my enemies but when i
buy those worms i don't want uncle sam
snooping around and taxing me on my
revenge worms you might not know this
but netflix has different content
available to users depending on where
they're located watching netflix without
using expressvpn is like paying for a
gym membership but only being able to
use a treadmill who wants that who's
ever done that expressvpn lets you
change your online location so you can
control where you want netflix to think
you're located they have almost 100
different server locations so you can
get those worms from wherever you want
say you're in france buying those worms
maybe the cayman islands where they're
not going to attack you too much huh a
little offshore worm buy-in so you can
gain access to thousands of new movies
and shows this works with other
streaming services like bbc iplayer
youtube and more personally i sometimes
feel like i've watched all of netflix
and it's really nice to be able to click
a few buttons boom i have a whole new
netflix to watch open the app select the
location tap one button to connect
refresh the page to access the
geo-restricted show you watched
expressvpn has the added benefit of
encrypting your data so you can browse
the web securely and buy all those
little creepy crawly worms and send them
to the kid who used to bully you on the
bus and sing songs into your ear and rip
your underwear now you can send them
poison worms from ecuador if you want no
one will ever know thank you expressvpn
so be smart stop paying full price for
streaming services and only getting
access to a fraction of their content
get your money's worth at
expressvpn.com rogue don't forget to use
our link at expressvpn.com
get an extra three months of expressvpn
for
free
[Music]
along with all the films coming out next
year marvel is rolling out a slate of
new series on disney plus
which one will stand above the rest
that's our second topic for today
friends
moon knight for she-hulk vs ms marvel vs
i am groot for secret invasion versus
the heartbreak kid this weekend only
at the pontiac silverdome who will have
the biggest mcu impact rumors from the
set of moon nights suggest the show may
be undergoing a few days of reshoots but
as we look ahead in 2022 in marvel
disney plus which of these series will
have the biggest impact on the mcu as a
whole looking back at 2021 the roles
seem to either be one division or loki
which of the upcoming story lines will
have the biggest breach all around the
biggest reach around
[Laughter]
oh jessica's
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay so i think
the upcoming uh mcu show that will have
the most impact is agatha house of
heartless oh
i think this because
at the end of spider-man uh far from no
no way home that's the one that just
came out uh we had that clip of doctor
strange and multiverse of madness and in
a quick blink of it we saw the back star
jacket of one america chavez so i think
that's going to be her introduction to
the mcu for sure
and that movie's coming out next i
believe sometime early in 2022.
so uh
it'll be heard dealing with doctor
strange the multiverse and a bunch of
magic stuff we saw the dark version of
doctor strange in that trailer cut up so
i think we'll see a lot of american
chavez and her universe uh
jumping skills and powers mixed in with
magic and a whole bunch of introductions
and stuff but i think she will be in ag
of the house of harkness and will
introduce us not only to new universes
and new characters but also a lot of the
young avengers characters that have been
kind of teed up um we got uh uh the the
teenage boy who's gonna be the new kind
of young captain america and uh the
witcher soldier in falcon show
we've got other people who've been teed
up and teased we've got uh miss marvel
coming up
so i think it'll be an introduction to
magic in a new way that we haven't seen
yet in the mcu america chavez also known
as miss america and also young justice
sorry not young justice wrong
cinematic universe uh young avengers
and
it might be an introduction to mutants i
think
yeah coming in with miss
america and like a reverse wanda right
yeah like yes mutants right yes
yes
yes more mutants yes and i think so
mutants yeah i think boss may have said
this in another video but yeah uh the
name agatha house of harkness might be a
kind of nod to the house of em so an
introduction to
mutants this way through house of
partners
and america chavez will probably pop up
in the house of hawking show introducing
us to a bunch of new [ __ ] that other uh
studios can lend to marvel now that
marvel was a big powerhouse
very interesting very much i
thought we were only choosing from the
ones you gave us
well eric you know what that was rogue
it's outside
draw within the lines i am a sheep um i
think i am a sheep i am a follower i
will do anything that you ask so
beautiful
it was between
secret invasion and miss marvel for me
but i ultimately am going to lean miss
marvel because
i love all the women in it but
but i think miss marvel is going to be a
big deal especially because miss marvel
is setting up um the marvels so i think
those being attached to each other so
not only are you getting miss marvel
we're getting carol danvers and we're
getting tiana paris is monica rambo so i
think all of those
coming together these are women that can
just like shoot into space basically and
that are fighting things in space so i
think secret invasion is very important
yes i think that's going to be a big
turning point for the mcu because you're
dealing with like different people from
different planets but i think
they are setting up
carol danvers and like captain marvel to
always be there and to like try to
always throw her into things i think
they're kind of shoving in there so i
think a good way to shove her in there
and then if she has to go do other
complicated stuff is by putting um
monica rambo or the girl from um miss
marvel so i think those are gonna be big
turning points because we also can put
miss marvel with young justice for the
young avengers sorry
with the young avengers or just with all
the younger people and then we have
monica rambo who's she's still like an
agent you know like her mom was a big
head honcho so they're coming from three
different three different like uh
franchi not franchise three different
movies three different backgrounds i
think they're gonna each have to tie
into the mcu ultimately in a really big
picture so i think they are the turning
point
and i stayed within the box uh this
rogue theory i was like i'm gonna stay
as grounded as possible
uh show off
yeah
i follow the rules give me extra point
money please
give me more than give me money
yes i did mention there will be a prize
at the end uh all right okay okay all
right matt what do you got for us i
think first off great question uh and
it's a very hard answer and i think uh
where i want to go with this and we're
the like i want to start by saying we've
the last 10 years we've i think we've
the marvel has played it very steady
it's very grounded as we talked about
earlier uh and we built on this universe
and now we're at a point after like end
game and everything and even wan
division
we've accepted there is a universal kind
of acceptedness uh across the fandom of
like the weird and and you know and the
bizarre so i think from here on out it's
gonna get crazy town right like
especially after loki and stuff so every
single show that you've listed i think
will impact the universe in a different
way building to a different kind of end
goal for example i think moon night
we've it's been confirmed that moon
knight is going to be dealing with
vampires so i think moon knight is the
introduction to
vampires and even dracula i think we
might even see like that might be like
the teaser uh it might he might be
dealing with a uh i forgot who's playing
the bad guy in it but that might be like
in someone serving dracula and that will
lead into blade and i'll open up the
dark universe right
and she-hulk i think that's going to be
a little more grounded and that's going
to be uh you know they who control new
york kind of a deal um i think it's
going to be uh the most ground of all
out of all of these that like i said
kind of talk about what we were talking
about before we'll deal with like wilson
fisk and dealing with you know who
controls new york city now um you know
especially after the avengers are kind
of like you know everyone's like what's
uh oh hold on one sec i'm getting my
things mixed up the avengers they're
still cool right do people still like
them
can you take this out i forgot yes the
avengers are still cool because steve
rogers has a musical
okay thank you thank you i like i got
like a little lost uh all right here we
go something's really hard to keep track
of same yeah yeah uh but yeah but i
think she-hulk is gonna be the battle
kind of like of new york because no
one's really kind of claimed it's kind
of open battlefield right now for who's
going to have like the low-key power for
it uh and i think she-hulk is going to
be doing a lot of defending uh and might
even team up with like you know where my
even intro like maybe like
mr fantastic or something so she might
introduce more new york central heroes
uh so that would open up that world uh i
think i'm cheating because i'm going
down all of them uh i agree with jess
about miss marvel miss marvel will deal
with captain marvel and and she is the
key to the young avengers and i think
miss marvel's show will also lead into
kind of like a um you know uh there's a
young superhero act that that started in
comics a few years ago that was like a
whole little thing where like if you're
underage superheroes can't be like do a
thing so i think that might be a
storyline that miss marvel will be
central for and that's how we're gonna
you know kate bishop and all these other
and all these other younger characters
will kind of band together to deal with
that kind of threat and i think that
she's gonna bring in the inhumans again
i don't think we're done with inhumans i
think we're going to get humans back
in humans or x-men uh i think the
weakest i don't think i am groot i think
that might be just like a fun
silly show sounds like it sounds really
cute you know i hope it's like the
scottie young comics because those are
great uh i think they have the lowest
impact and i do think secret invasion
might be the big thing that we're all
leading up to
with all these like there's a lot of
things at play here secret invasion
might be the thing that like kind of
throws a wrench into all of the
plays uh in all these shows so i kind of
cheated by going talking about all the
but i do think of building a different
thing so secretly
as uh as as degeneration x john michaels
would say if you ain't cheating you
ain't trying so uh what the [ __ ] i will
accept that answer now let's award a few
uh sweet chin musics eric uh
you did not obey the rules of the game
at all you were so rogue that you went
beyond the year that we asked the
question so instead of a sweet chin
music i'm just going to give you a ric
flair chop uh one ric flair chop
that but that's still worth something
that's not worth nothing not sure uh
matt you listed in order of the question
each show and listed some very fun
plot lines that could go with the show
so i'm going to give you uh one sweet
chin music for that effort
but jessica yum yum yum yum women who
could fight on earth and fly into space
get me a girl who can do both
two sweet chin musics but the second one
is the sweet chin music that shawn
michaels gave to ric flair in his
retirement match with tears in his eyes
when he went i'm so sorry and then he
kicked ric flair in the face and pinned
him so you get the ric flair retirement
sweet chin music
which is maybe the most valuable sweet
chin music of all now everyone as you
know on this show you are responsible
for keeping track of your own points i
will not simply will not keep track of
what you have uh but this game is still
wide open guys we're nowhere near the
end i think we still got another hour
and a half left to go here uh
so let me ask you today's rogue question
and in the end this is the only question
that's really going to matter because
recency bias is how i live my life what
have you done for me lately
uh it was reported this week that the
upcoming the batman film from dc will be
rated pg-13 no
but i'm almost 40 and i want the movie
to be edgy and dark for me i want batman
to kill i want batman to bone i don't
want any teenagers
leaving that movie without thinking
batman is raw dogging catwoman okay it's
not for them it's for me damn it all
right anyway pitch me your ideas on what
batman catwoman and the riddler or any
other character from the film could have
done to get that r rating
just calling farrell as the penguin is
having a big ol orgy at the iceberg
casino
there's no reason for it
tips to
i re-watched batman returns and some of
the [ __ ] that like dan devito says i
don't know how that didn't get r-rated
yeah yeah just go the extra step there
it is it was the early 90s you know
people weren't as worried about it then
all right what else you got for me guys
well i think uh because pg-13 is a rated
r a couple of things have to happen i
think pg-13 movies get one yes that's
true yeah and there's a lot more blood
in r-rated movies like in a pg-13 movie
you can get punched in the mouth and
bleed a little bit but you can't have
like blood coming out of bullets and
whatnot so
i think what needs to happen is batman
and catwoman have a sex scene where he
does eat that kitty cat
and
she scratches him in the middle of it
blood comes out and he's like oh
that would have gotten them
wow yes speaking of which you should
read my fan fiction sometimes i'd love
to something very similar happens does
he maintain his like voice
i need a bandage
alfred give me give me a band-aid
all right jessica what do you got for me
um
those are really good i like the idea of
saying eat the kitty cat from the back
um
so
zack snyder would approve apparently
exactly zack snyder loves it um
he zack snyder would do his own cut
where he just put hallelujah behind it
by
god
i'm afraid by even mentioning
yes by even mentioning zack snyder like
we're all like yeah we're gonna get like
twitter twitter
i told them that i don't mind zack
snyder it's that a lot of
it's we'll talk about it on twitter you
guys can have me um i think yeah exactly
what i want i think
um there should be a scene for it to
just because i don't uh thank you
for telling me what makes the what what
needs to be the pg-13 to rated r because
i truly was like doesn't it just need to
be more violent
um
so i think there should be a scene where
catwoman is like fighting
and then like the riddler breaks into
catwoman's apartment she's fighting and
then she sticks her cats on them and the
cats are tearing him apart i want the
cats to be ripping pieces of flesh out i
want these cats to be aggressive and i
know movies like to kill cats i want the
cats i wanted to go backwards i want the
cats to kill the riddler so i want her
to be like sitting there in her chair
and the cats are tearing him apart and
that's the little part that had to be
make it rated r wow well uh
i i like the roll i like the reversal
there i think that's really good uh
unfortunately the correct answer is that
alfred tells the aristocrats
so that's uh that's that's how that goes
no just kidding jessica
you get the final sweet chin music for
reverse murderous pussycats bang and i
believe that makes you our winner for
today and your major prize
is uh
i'll come wash your car sometime in a
bikini oh my god i need that thank you
folks
ladies and gentlemen our winner today
jessica clement
thank you thank you thank you jessica of
course as i said before i will come to
your house uh at the date of your
choosing and wash your car in nothing
but a bikini and a smile that is it for
this action-packed episode of rogue
theory thank you so much to our guests
jessica clemons
matt acevedo and erica wusu you guys
were fantastic it's always a pleasure to
work with you guys please support our
channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
if you've got some thoughts on some of
our rogue theories then you can share
them on our discord if you're over 18
search for the new rockstars discord
server and join that conversation you
can follow me at new rocks ah you can
follow no you can't follow me any
rockstars follow me at tommy bechtol
follow the rockstars on all social
platforms and be sure to subscribe to
our channel here on youtube see you next
time
[Music]
you